bonjour inhesj et merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors manuel macro annoncé
hier une prime exceptionnelle et des
heures supplémentaires majorées pour
l'ensemble des personnels soignants et
des fonctionnaires mobilisez votre
sentiment sur les dernières annonces du
gouvernement elle mon sentiment c'est
que ça fait un an qu'on inverse sur la
situation qui est très tendue à
l'hôpital bon on n'est pas là pour
parler de ça aujourd'hui mais et les
mesures elles vont dans le bon sens bon
après ça fait déjà trois fois qu'on nous
promet des plans et qui sont pas
exactement tel qu'on les attend après
voilà donc ce genre dans le bon sens il
faut réévaluer les carrières sonnant
laisse les mulets et version mais là ce
dont on a besoin de manière vraiment
très urgente c'est des matériels de
protection comme vous l'avez dit la
plainte elle est motivée par la france
d'équipements de protection individuelle
mais aussi de test de moyens et des
décisions à même de protéger le
personnel hospitalier est donc le reste
la population en amont on a vraiment de
nombreux collègues qui sont contaminés
et lit les chiffres l'ap-hp sont mis à
jour régulièrement il ya environ mille
d'entre 6 et 7 fautes personnelles qui
sont contaminés est encore là on parle
que des gens qui sont testés sur leur
politique c'est quand même de faire le
mode de test possible
évidemment quand on n en ai pas testé
ont cette passion les positifs alors le
chef de l'état elle a également promis
un 29000 test va vont être effectués
chaque jour est ce que vous estimez que
c'est suffisant et alors je les vois les
promesses j'aime aussi j'attends de voir
ce qui va arriver sur le terrain nous
promet beaucoup de choses
après ce que ce qui est concret par
exemple des on a fait une collecte de
données au niveau du collectif qui est
en plaques est amenée à évoluer
évidemment mais pour l'instant on sait
que les trois quarts des soignants
interrogés se sentent pas en sécurité
dans leur travail leur sécurité et les
très corrélés à ceux qui disent se
sentir en sécurité ses sections du
matériel de protection alors il faut
déteste ça a été recommandé par l'om et
il faut tester massivement la population
et ça s'est rencontrés depuis longtemps
et ça a pas été fait des livres
bon en tout cas cette plainte elle a
pour objectif d'accélérer la prise de
décision et on voit que ça arrive est en
tout cas ce dont on a besoin c'est pas
de promesses et d'actions concrètes
alors ce jeudi le conseil d'état examine
plusieurs référé d'infirmiers concernant
la demande de masques ou encore
la prescription de chloroquine quelle
est aujourd'hui la priorité si vous
deviez en choisir une j'imagine que
c'est la protection est avant tout la
protection de vos collègues
oui pour moi c'est vraiment la
protection alors je parle des
professionnels de santé parce que je
connais mais je pense qu'ils aux autres
personnes qui travaillent comme vous les
connaissez donc vous avez parlé mais
c'est vraiment d d d équipements de
protection individuelle des tests comme
ça a été recommandé par l'om s est par
exemple je fais comme ça a été demandé
par le conseil scientifique mais il ya
déjà un moment la prolongation du
confinement scellés et décisions
annoncées sont pas claires pour bien
comprendre aujourd'hui on imagine votre
quotidien d'infirmier ou ou
d'infirmières qui doit être qui doit
être insoutenable pour vous est-ce que
vous pouvez voir un peu nous raconter
quel est votre quotidien
alors moi je suis dans nos services très
mobile des réanimations donc su je fais
pas partie des plus touchés mais aussi
pour moi le matériel est compté mais
quand je vais déposer des patients chez
mes collègues aux urgences que je vois
c'est elle finançait il faut il faut qui
pleurnichent pour avoir des protections
et les protections sont comptés en leur
donne un amour de masques lui limité en
début de schiste enfin je parle je pense
sûrement je pense aussi aux réalisations
sens au style qu'on appelle les unit et
kobe et les unités dans lesquelles les
patientes sont 1 2 et positif au cours
d'un virus sont hospitalisés quand ils
ont la nécessité et en termes de
protection mais on n'est pas bon on
n'est pas bon il faut savoir que ne pas
avoir de protection parce qu'il faut la
demander à chaque fois qu'on rentre dans
une chambre à un cadre par exemple ça
produit du renoncement c'est à dire que
si vous avez une urgence à gérer vital
beau temps qui vous rentrez dans la
chambre de son sens dans les protections
et sas ça engendre des prises de risque
et ça met en danger la population et les
élus
dernière question rapidement votre
ressenti pour les prochains jours vous
est confiante pessimiste vis-à-vis de
cette crise sanitaire
oula ça moi je préfère pas me projeter
ça sert de faire des dégâts et des
grands plans parce que ce dont j'ai
envie
pour les prochains jours c'est que les
décisions soient claires qu'on nous
donne du matériel pour travailler
et qu'on me donne les moyens de l'ujf
chili merci beaucoup
inès guerre je rappelle que vous êtes
infirmier à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris et membre du collectif inter
urgence